[Music]
before we start this video
i just want to quickly mention that only
20 of you are subscribed
and only 17.9 of subscribers
have clicked the bell if you enjoy the
content and want to support the channel
please consider subscribing and turning
on notifications
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing old voldemort
as well as a whole bunch of other
characters more specifically
we're going to be looking at voldemort's
unique relationship to these characters
for you see it was voldemort that killed
them
voldemort is the primary antagonist in
the harry potter story
taking over from grindelwald who
tyrannized the wizarding world for
decades prior
he was a misguided young boy turned
notorious dark wizard
who had a very specific agenda
re-established
pureblood rule of the wizarding world
interestingly enough
voldemort wasn't a pureblood himself but
that didn't stop him
and he did unthinkable things in his
efforts to achieve
power he was willing to do whatever it
took
and this meant that he was even willing
to kill
actually he was more than eager to kill
if any kind of opportunity
presented itself what i want to look at
today is just how many people voldemort
killed
in addition to his enemies voldemort
killed a lot of his own allies
and even muggles who had no concept or
notion of the wizarding world
many of the deaths that voldemort was
responsible for
however were not acts committed by
voldemort himself
they were acts committed in voldemort's
name by his followers
the death eaters without further ado
let's get into it
and see which people voldemort killed
with his own wand
please bear in mind that while i'm
constructing this list i'm going to do
my best
to balance the events of the books and
films in ferry
i'm going to start off with all of the
witches wizards and muggles
that voldemort killed and later turned
into a ferry
killing people and turning them into a
ferry wasn't a one-off occasion
he murdered people for years to build
his army and so it's hard to pinpoint on
the timeline
he must have been killing for years to
acquire the hordes of corpses
that attacked harry in the cave the
riddle family
when he was just 16 years old tom riddle
returned to the riddle house in little
hangalton
and exacted his revenge upon his family
his father who had abandoned him and his
mother
was his first victim shortly thereafter
he killed the remaining muggles in his
heritage
his grandparents mary and thomas riddle
at this stage
tom covered up his crimes by altering
morphine's memory
causing him to believe that he murdered
the riddles this resulted in morphin
gaunt
being sent to azkaban hepsipa smith
one of voldemort's first proper murders
was hebsiba smith
a witch that claimed to be a descendant
of hogwarts founder helga hufflepuff
after discovering that hebsipa was in
possession of helga hufflepuff's cup
and salazar's through the rinse locket
riddle killed hebzebur
in order to obtain these valuable
artifacts riddle framed smith's house
elf
hokie who was extremely old and
forgetful mughal
around the age of 31 one year or less
after obtaining salazar's slithering's
locket
voldemort killed an unnamed mughal
in order to turn the locket into a
horcrux
albanian peasant the next murder on
record was when voldemort killed an
unnamed albanian peasant
in order to turn rowena ravenclaw's
diadem into a horcrux
there's a substantial 10-year gap
between voldemort killing the mughal
and the albanian peasant and i suspect
that voldemort killed
many other unnamed people between those
years
goblin family sometime in the 70s
voldemort killed an unnamed
nottingham-based goblin family during
the first wizarding war
i'm sure they'd never go to you know who
they've suffered losses too
remember that goblin family he murdered
last time somewhere near nottingham
marlene mckinnon in the year 1981
voldemort killed witch marlene mckinnon
a member of the original order of the
phoenix
the mckinnon family was one that was
eventually completely wiped out by
voldemort
and the death eaters dorcas meadows
another member of the original order of
the phoenix dorchest meadows was a very
talented witch
that suffered her fate the hands of
voldemort parents of amelia bones
1981 was a ruthless year for voldemort
when it came to murders
and it was in this same year that he
murdered mr and mrs bones
the parents of amelia bones who would
later become head of the department of
magical law enforcement
lily and james potter lily and james
potter were two of lord voldemort's most
notable victims
the parents of harry potter their deaths
were also two of the most
significant ones as it was lily's
sacrificial protection
that temporarily stopped voldemort
putting an end to the first wizarding
war
when the prophecy declared that their
son harry was in danger
they went into hiding but on halloween
in 1981 voldemort found them
and ended their lives bertha jorkins
bertha jorkin's ministry employee was
voldemort's first
significant murder after he was defeated
in the first wizarding war
in 1994 jorkins went on holiday to
albania
a holiday that she would never return
home from lord voldemort
savagely killed her with the killing
curse it was jokkin's death that allowed
voldemort to turn nagini
into a horcrux frank bryce frank
price was a muggle that lived in little
hangalton he was the groundskeeper for
the riddle house
and was murdered by voldemort after
overhearing his plan
to kill harry potter florian fortescue
florian fortescue was a british wizard
and the owner
of florian fortescue's ice cream parlor
in diagon alley
unfortunately in the summer of 1996 he
was abducted
and later murdered by lord voldemort
harry once questioned what had happened
to him
florian used to give me free ice creams
what's happened to him
dragged off by the look of his place
amelia bones
in july of 1996 during the summer
holidays
emilia bones was murdered in her own
home for anti-voldemort activities
this was 15 years after her parents had
been murdered by him
german family in september of 1997
voldemort killed an unnamed and
unsuspecting german family
who lived in the former home of
wandmaker miku grakorovich
when he arrived at the home expecting to
find grakovic
the family explained to him that he no
longer lived there however
this answer was not satisfactory to
voldemort and he killed them with the
killing curse
harry saw this happen via his telepathic
connection with voldemort
alistair moody aleister madday moody
died
during the battle of the seven potters
during this battle
the order of the phoenix attempted to
transport harry from privet drive to the
borough
this was a dangerous mission as death
eaters were waiting for them
after taking polyjuice potion they used
the buddy system to break the group
apart
hoping that it would make it more
difficult to target the real harry
moody was partnered with mandungus
fletcher and
when faced with voldemort mandungus
disapperated
causing voldemort's killing curse to hit
moody in the face
charity burbidge charity burbidge was
the professor of muggle studies at
hogwarts
and she was killed by voldemort in 1997
after writing an article defending
mudbloods that was subsequently
published in the daily prophet
not content with corrupting and
polluting the minds of wizarding
children
last week professor burbidge wrote an
impassioned defense of mudbloods
in a daily prophet rufus scrimga rufus
scrimga was an aura
and for a short period minister for
magic he was eventually captured by
voldemort and questioned
when scrimga gave him no answers he was
killed by the dark lord
miku gragorovich miku gragorovich was a
famous wand maker that purportedly
possessed the elder wand
voldemort eventually tracked him down
and demanded he give him the wand
when grogorovich explained that the wand
had been stolen from him
years ago voldemort killed him with the
killing curse
goblins and guards of gringotts shortly
after harry broke into gringotts bank
employees of the bank including griphook
rickbert and teffington
were summoned to malfoy manor where
voldemort killed them
gelet grindelwald gelet grindelwald the
preeminent dark figure in the wizarding
world before voldemort
was imprisoned in nurmengard in 1998
voldemort visited grindelwald in the
prison
and when grindelwald refused to give him
information regarding the elder wand
voldemort ended his life with the
killing curse voldemort
last but not least on a list of people
voldemort killed we have
voldemort himself as we know in the
final battle between harry and voldemort
voldemort's killing curse ends up
rebounding back at him resulting in his
own death
i know what you're thinking now some
names are missing on this list
that's because though voldemort was
responsible for some other major deaths
he didn't actually pull the trigger
himself these deaths include
myrtle warren who was killed by the
basilisk quirrell who was killed by
harry
after being possessed by voldemort the
tilde bagshot who is likely killed by
nagini
cedric diggory whose death came after
voldemort ordered pettigrew to kill him
peter pettigrew who was killed by the
silver hand voldemort had given him
and lastly severus snape who was killed
by nagini
on voldemort's command and that's it for
this video
who did i miss i tried my best to get
them all but i'm sure i still may have
missed a few
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
remember you're a wizard harry